alors corinne ce temps ben est pas
content à peine toujours corinne de
téléphone un peu comme quelqu'un que
regarder son nom de jeune fille alors
maintenant tu es plutôt corrie les
visiteurs j'ai divorcé ouais je ne suis
plus la parole de téléphone va contester
visiteurs mais voilà téléphone dont
c'était le plus grand groupe de rock
français vous étiez un peu avec richard
comme harrison et ringo starr c'est à
dire que gérer les deux villes où la
aubert et bertignac qui écrivaient les
chansons ça posait pas de problème vous
montre la répartition des droits parce
que les vidéos du jour n'ont eu des
problèmes oui il y en a toujours un
petit peu dans la tente où les groupes
chez téléphone sainteté relativement
simple ouais alors ils ont fait un plan
jeger richard doux lennon mccartney ils
ont ils indiqué ils ont divorcé et toi
pourquoi tu as choisi bertignac parce
que j'ai toujours choisi bertignac
depuis le départ
on est arrivés d'un téléphone deux par
deux un côté ambert que d'une caille de
côté bertignac mark leno et en est
reparti comme on était venu est plus
tentant d'aider la cover quand même je
m'entendais on peut pas faire ce genre
d' aventure si on ne s'entend pas bien
tu préfères berthet j'ai choisi